距离你稳定盈利只差最后一次调参数
这次调完真的不一样了
MACD从1269换成627
KTJ从933换成633
均线从20日调到18日
又调到15日
每次回测看着都挺漂亮
幸好比上一个版本敏锐多了
假突破好像也少了
你心里清楚
这次大概率还是一样的结局
但你不甘心
万一这一次真的对了呢
这个循环如果不停下来
你会在同一个地方反复磨损
不是磨损账户
是磨损你对指标的信任
磨损到最后你打开图标里
看见润特指标都觉得烦
觉得全是骗子
这个循环的起点是一个藏得很深的
假设你假设同一类指标里一定有一个最准的
只要把它找出来
或者把参数调到最优交易就能上一个台阶
但如果你仔细想想
同一类指标之间的差别
远远没有你想象中那么大
KDJ和RSI一个用最高最低价算相对位置
一个用涨跌幅算强度比例
算法看着不一样
但他们回答的是同一个问题
价格是不是走的太快了
大部分时候他们的超买超卖信号
前后脚出现插不了几根K线
你换的不是指标
是指标的皮肤
同一碗汤换个碗端给你
你以为是新菜
e ma和SMA一个给近期价格更高的权重
一个所有天数平均对待EMA比SMA快一点
SMA比e ma稳一点
但它们给你的核心信息是一样的
价格是在均线上方运行还是下方运行
均线方向是向上还是向下
你在这两根线之间反复横跳
不如就认准一根
一直用这个道理
说穿了其实很简单
但有意思的是
你每天都能在社交媒体上刷到另一群人
他们还在孜孜不倦的表演同一件事
晒一张回撤图
参数调出了一个爆炸声率
牛逼啊
这个人过两周再刷到
它
又是一个新参数
又是一张新回撤图
上次那个参数跑哪去了
不知道不重要
因为这次调的更牛
下次你在评论区看到这种人艾特我
让我们一起去问问他
美国国债要不要他来
还能把参数调到这个胜率
全世界最赚钱的营生应该不是交易
是帮他管钱
那为什么换了指标
有时候确实有不一样的结果
不是因为新指标更准
是因为你在换指标的时候
刚刚好换在了旧指标的回撤期
一个指标连续给你几次假信号
你就觉得它不行了
但任何指标都有回撤期
趋势类指标在震荡四会被反复打脸
震荡类指标在趋势四会一直钝化
他不是突然坏了
是行情走到了他不擅长的阶段
你在这个时候换掉它
新指标刚上来可能正好赶上行情切换
你觉得新指标神了
但等行情再换一轮
新指标也会进入它的回撤期
你又想换了
这不叫优化
这叫追着行情屁股后面跑
那到底怎么选一个指标定下来
不用看胜率
不用看回测报告
看一个东西就够了
这个指标给你的信号你看得清楚吗
金叉就是金叉
死叉就是死叉
没有模棱两可的中间地带吗
信号出来之后
你是马上知道该做什么
还是会盯着他犹豫半天
顺眼是选指标最重要的标准
因为它能直接决定你能不能一直用它
一个你看不顺眼的指标
连续做两三次
你就想换一个你看得顺眼的错了
你也会觉得是正常的
回撤期不会手痒
你和一个指标之间的关系
本质上就是你和你自己的交易系统之间的关系
你信他
他给你的信号你才敢执行
你不信他
他给你再多惊诧
你都能在脑子里找出一个理由来否决他
那参数怎么处理
默认参数就够用
就不要调默认参数
之所以是默认
是因为它经过大量市场数据检验的通用解
它不是最灵敏的
不是最稳定的
但那是大多数行情下相对平稳的那个点
你动了它就是在灵敏度和稳定性之间做了交换
调快了假信号就多
调慢了
进场就晚
没有免费的午餐
只有一个情况值得你调参数
你的交易周期和默认参数的时间框架
明显不匹配
KDJ默认参数是933
是基于9日周期设计的
如果你是做30分钟级别短线的
9日等于你大半个交易周过去了
这时候可以适当调快一点
让指标跟你的周期对齐
但调到什么程度
调到信号
在你做决策的时间窗口里能看清楚就够了
不要为了抢先一步调的更快
越快越不准
参数调整最容易犯的错是连续亏损之后去调
你觉得这几天怎么做怎么错
一定是参数有问题
但其实你回测一下就知道
同样的参数在上个月还是赚钱的
不是参数突然坏了
是行情变了
连续亏损的时候调参数
你调的不是参数
是心态
调完之后大概率会更乱
回到开头那个念头
你离稳定盈利真的只差最后一次调参数吗
还是你已经在同一个地方绕了太久
久到不愿意停下来
想一想
是不是这条路从头就不对
你真正缺的也许不是那个对参数
而是放弃追逐下一个参数的决心
选一个看得顺眼的指标
参数又默认的把它用至少三个月
三个月里别换别调
这个过程中你会发现它有时候对
有时候错
有时候连续错
你去错的时候
你特别想换
特别想调参数轮住
因为你要看到的不是他错了几次
是你三个月之后
你对它的信号有没有形成记录记忆
你咨询他的时候还犹不犹豫
犹豫才是最贵的成本信号
不清楚让你犹豫一次
小尝试过
让你犹豫一次
换了新指标
不熟悉
又让你犹豫一次
这些犹豫加起来比你选错指标的代价大得多
等你用三个月把犹豫磨没了
这个指标才真正变成了你的指标